台灣股市連續三天下跌
但是跌中有序
下跌過程中有秩序的
有些股票慢慢拉起來
精材我們好像連5天上漲了
我真的懶得數我賺多少了
我不想那麼行銷
反正你們自己數
可是我要告訴你
台灣股市連續3天下跌
大家最想要知道台積電營收
創高了 有沒有救
這個營收有夠漂亮
第二個 被動元件午盤急拉
我是不是說AI會造福各位
我昨天告訴大家
3年內台灣股市有機會上10萬點
都上新聞了
我打個哈欠 打個噴嚏
現在也可以上新聞
現在還能追嗎
被動元件午盤急拉是所為何事
盤中工商時報
也出現一個讓他急拉的新聞
是為什麼
第三個 明晚CPI通膨數據如何解讀
這三個獨家的思考
我告訴你 獨家的告訴你
你今天一定要鎖定我的節目
大家好 我是摩爾投顧投資長
郭哲榮分析師
也是全台灣唯一百萬
甚至140萬粉絲的分析師
你要找找最紅的
你們家有沒有
我們來看一下這個台積電
我們先講台積電營收好不好
你們想先看什麼
你們趕快回答我
台積電營收
還是被動元件為什麼漲 好不好
趕快 來
先看台積電營收好不好
我這個就不臭屁了
先跟你講這個不臭屁了
3374精材我就不臭屁了
投資朋友有沒有看到
我是不是說
這個中實戶洗完盤以後
會漲得很恐怖
我是不是說可能要600
但是可能600
不代表這是目標價或是一定
我先跟你講 我是合格分析師
不要給我扯遠
這個投資有上有下的
我先跟大家講
我這個都是很務實的
來 哲哲也不缺會員
可是最近哲哲的行情
掌握的真好
我這個績效
我自認為是這幾年績效最好的
不是以前不好 而是今年特別好
大家都知道 有目共睹
我們看一下 先來看一下台積電好了
因為我沒有要做生意
所以我先來看台積電
不然我至少講個被動元件
台積電有沒有看到 來
8月營收有看到嗎
所以台積電
你看 你們看這個樹狀圖就知道
歷史新高就算了
你有沒有覺得他高的特別多
助理你給我另外一個東西好不好
我看起來應該是年增率最高的時候
你們看 為什麼我說看起來年增率最高
你看4600到5100大概10%
4600到4400不到10%
就是什麼叫10%
就是月增率
就是台積電一下突破10%
聽得懂嗎
就是以前雖然4170億到4427億
5月到6月的營收
但是他不會增加10%
他沒有增加10%
助理給我三竹的那些
看一下數據 就月增知道答案了
所以以前沒有增加這麼多
現在一下增加10%
以月增來看的話很漂亮
但是以這一季的進度來講的話
大概現在67.9%
聽不懂就算了
就是現在3個月嘛
一季的營收
到第二個月應該要66.67%達成率
現在大概是67.9%
比他還多1%
8月營收達成率 光單月
一個月達成率至少要33.3%
1除以3不就是33嗎
33.3% 聽得懂嗎
聽不懂沒關係啦
你什麼時候看過月增率這麼大
月增率這麼高 這樣懂不懂
而且這只是剛開始
理論上9月營收也不會太差 好
我們就說基本上台積電營收
不會衰退
就算衰退 除了2月
因為2月要休息 好不好
2月在休息 工作日也減少
除了2月以外你看到
他基本上不會衰退有沒有看到
4152億到4107億
就算衰退也衰退不多 沒有錯吧
我們除了2月 那個沒辦法
2月各個電子廠都這樣子
農曆年總會休息
所以再不濟我認為
8月有5100億的營收
所以這一次達成率
聽清楚喔
會超過百分之百
當然它是用台幣
我們是用台幣計價啦
助理上你這是用
是台幣計價的達成率嗎
是不是你告訴我一下
所以再講一次
這一季的達成率
第三季的達成率
7 8 9月的達成率
會超過百分之百的機率很高
我先給你預告
我是專業分析師 我先跟你預告
因為台積電下個月
還有機會歷史新高
為什麼 我告訴你喔
蘋果手機出來啦
摺疊機要不要買
今天有什麼什麼紅
Rosé是什麼紅
去查一下Rosé的蘋果手機
我有蘋果手機有做圖
等一下跟大家講一下
這樣懂不懂 好不好
我們來看一下大家
所以台積電營收好
股價怎麼 台股怎麼會差
就說5萬點啦
那個TVBS
3年10萬點上新聞好不好 來
被動尾盤90度急拉
你們要知道被動我早就講了
被動元件拉尾盤
環球晶洗很大
環球晶就跟前陣子的被動元件有什麼差
星期一不是說
國巨3天內會接近漲停板
不要急 不要急
華新科有嘛
後來有修正
我說明天喔 我說這一週喔
而且 來
星期一不是說
國巨3天內會接近漲停板
我有說一定嗎
第二個 明天還有一天
第三個 如果哲哲預言一下
就要被你嗆一下
請你走
不好意思 至少我敢預言
就不要明天給我拉起來
明天拉起來的機率很高 好不好
我不需要 我這邊不需要酸民
我不缺粉絲
哲哲講話很跩 不好意思
因為我自己知道
我對你們真的很好 好不好 OK
等明天嘛 是不是
我後來有跟你講說
明天再看看嘛 是不是
正要講
為什麼明天反而有機會拉起來
國巨 就算國巨沒有
明天華新科也有機會
來 我們再看一下台積電
台積電有沒有到
月增率有沒有看到
這是台積電有沒有看到 好
你不能看 你不能說2月
2月下跌20%
然後升到30%
2月你不要理他
那是因為2月太低了
才變成3月高 你聽得懂嗎
你看我們達成率來看一下
今年以來有沒有到
3月以來 4月以來
很少10%有沒有到
那時候前陣子才3100多億
去年12月3000多億
3300億
現在已經變5000億了 扯不扯
所以台積電今天的不錯 很好
那這叫做解讀財報
這是一般分析師做的
台灣有很多漲停板的分析師
是連解都不解
你看 或稍微講一下
你看我的股票
CPO強講CPO
什麼股票強講
光學股強講光學股
你要聽去找他們
我不會針對某一個分析師
我講的是台灣的特有現況 好不好
有些分析師現況
我不做這種事情
那你去看一件事
那個講完台積電了
那我只告訴你
AGI你們還是聽不懂
AGI就像這樣子
這個畫面這樣子 你看
比如說AGI
AGI比如說我叫你搜尋噴出第一根
他會用程式跑
然後2492 然後3374
切畫面 只要看軟體就好
可以嗎
可以啊 不是嗎
導播 你聽不懂我的意思嗎
我們在念簡訊的感覺
對 要聽得懂
來 AGI就像這樣子
他自己會找
你會覺得是我在動對不對
沒有 以後是個隱形的人在幫你動
幫你找精材 幫你找噴出第一根
他會掃描所有的東西
這樣子 然後滑鼠這樣子
然後幫你看一下損益
順便幫你看三大法人
甚至用程式跑
現在你感覺是我手在動對不對
沒有 以後就是電腦在動
這就是AGI啦
那跟AI agent差別在哪邊
AI agent以前還要你敘述每個過程
現在不必了
你只要稍微簡單一點就可以了
懂嗎 再看一次
AGI就是這樣子
這個
你現在覺得滑鼠是我動
以後滑鼠不是我動
我是認真的
你就彷彿有一個人在你旁邊
然後他幫你搜尋
什麼股票創新高 第一根
3374第一根
好恐怖喔
6196帆宣
他看一下搜尋
有沒有第一根
沒有第一根
他就不給你推薦了
第一根 他自己幫你下單
也可以
你只要講到什麼
他就可以做到什麼
就怕你不會問問題而已
這叫AGI 這樣懂意思嗎
而且AGI就算他沒學過也沒關係
他智商就一開始像零歲
他都沒學過這東西
他馬上可以變成18歲 20歲
而且智商比你還高
任何遊戲他都可以玩
任何規則他都可以適應
AGI最厲害的是
他可以無中生有
他可以舉一反三 懂嗎
而且我要告訴你喔
下一代AGI最晚半個年
現在已經第一代了喔
半年內 快的話三個月內
還會有下一代AGI
那再下一代呢 更快喔
我跟你講喔
你有沒有發現到
現在譬如說
你有用ChatGPT
Gemini就知道
他的版本越來越快
就是更新的速度越來越快
因為下一代會開始AI研究AI
這些我都預告在前面了
3年10萬點真的
所以有這個前提下
所以台積電營收才會創新高
你每天都看那個數字 變現
那是最落後
你看財報要幹什麼
那已經落後了 那跟不上
會計財報跟不上
你看現在營收也是慢的
那是上個月的事情了
現在AI是以天計算
一天就可以
甚至可能一天可以升一個版本
我沒跟你開玩笑
那是你們不懂AI
懂AI的人都佩服我
所以我為什麼點閱率這麼高
因為真的懂資料
真的我的粉絲跟會員
最多就是工程師
工程師你也知道
就是受不了人家講廢話
你要跟他講邏輯的話 你懂嗎
他們最喜歡看我的節目
看一下 自己查一下
跟我用AI的感覺一樣
你要知道他能用AGI以後產生
他能產生多少的能量
取代多少人的工作
那為什麼不投資呢
7500億
人類的工作是幾十兆美金一年
上百兆 幾百兆美金
7500億不到一兆
我只要取代2%到3%的人力就好了
那就2 3兆美金
我投資1兆又怎麼樣
我投資2兆又怎麼樣
而且不只取代那麼少人力
你要記我的邏輯
那些人 我看數字
那沒有用
行情一直給你也沒有用
我問你一件事
華新科為什麼急拉 為什麼
6173信昌電
為什麼直接拉漲停
為什麼嘛
來 看一下
別人笑我太瘋癲
我笑他人看不穿
這個村田擬常規 車規
MLCC停產有沒有看到 是不是
這不是跟2018年一樣嗎
2018年也是村田
有些部分的常規要停產
為什麼 這個我看到新聞我就知道
你要找
像我今天我不得不去法庭
我找的律師剛好他是法官出身的
他有些訴訟的一些原則
有些是議事攻防戰
就是法庭攻防戰
有些你根本就是
你不去找律師
你不找厲害的律師
你不找那個會懂法條的律師
你真的沒辦法跟人家抗衡 你懂嗎
就是譬如說對方找一個證人
你當場不找一個證人
以後就不能找了
那這些不找律師行嗎
你不找有經驗的律師行嗎
那剛好我找的律師
有法院經驗的 法官經驗的
如果我這次贏了
我說你要不要來上電視一下
推薦他一下
聽說他太太也常看我的節目
何太太你好 扯遠了
我今天看到那個訴訟案件
其實我覺得我也很無辜
對方真的很可惡
那個某個張姓分析師
把自己身體搞差了
我也覺得你何必呢
你也知道哲哲一定會
太誇張一定會反擊
我也不想啊
可是他叫我不提告他
好像就我是騙人一樣
那我當然得提告
我也不想浪費司法資源
我看他這樣子身體現在變差 我也是
真的他氣很虛
真的 我說真的
在現場的人都知道
然後視網膜前陣子剝離
他自己也承認了
心肌梗塞
心臟血管要開大刀
所以真的
我真的覺得各個同業不要這樣做
因為攻擊哲哲不會比較好
對方的業績也不會比較好
真的 真的
講到這個東西 為什麼扯遠了
對啦 我說律師要找有經驗的
哲哲砸錢都很願意
還我清白
所以各位同業跟各位網紅們
或各位網友們
請不要試著低估哲哲
願意捍衛我清白的任何決心跟時間
以及金錢
拜託 為什麼要講這東西
我說要找有經驗的
因為我看這個新聞就像2018年
你看哲哲真會扯 真會扯回來
2018年是常規停產 怎麼樣
為什麼 我去做比較有賺錢的就好了
不就跟DRAM一樣
為什麼一開始先漲DRAM
旺宏不漲
先漲南亞科 為什麼旺宏不漲
為什麼
因為那NAND Flash沒有那麼缺
現在不是嘛
現在DRAM缺了
我用NAND Flash去補他嘛
都缺嘛 HBM嘛
我AI伺服器
而且之前說南亞科是常規的
南亞科 台灣沒有做HBM
沒有做AI的DRAM
我不管 那我三星什麼
我三星 我海力士
我把我的產能移過去
我原本做DRAM的
我全部做高階的AI的DRAM
就是HBM
那我低階的DRAM我不做了
低階的DRAM我不做
我們低階的南亞科
南亞科大部分是做低階的DRAM
基本上就沒有做AI的DRAM
那我就賺到錢了
那連常規DRAM也不夠了 怎麼辦
再NAND Flash
一個牽一個
我轉產能 我要賺比較多錢的
現在車子賣不好 常規的賣不好
我不做了 我去做AI的
有相關的被動元件
答案不都一樣
我不是說什麼都是缺
那前提是什麼
前提是你要懂什麼是AGI
你要懂AI進步多少
你以為我昨天 前天
跟你講那麼多AI是幹什麼
我不是跟你唬爛
你告訴我哪個分析師可以講那麼仔細
他們連什麼是AGI都不懂
懂 那為什麼不講
我不是要攻擊別人
我現在都是一樣
我現在都是感覺做事情
要不要收會員我都很平常心
我真的希望能改變你的人生
我改變你的人生
像那個律師就講到說
律師有時候做股票
哲哲 那個
他應該有看我的節目 沒關係
哲哲 那個台勝科對不對
他說470買
台股NO.1掀開來的時候470
我說你不要這樣子嘛
我們一定很早進場嘛
我掀開牌的時候
有時候2根 3根漲停板
聽得懂嗎 現在410
我說你應該有解套吧
沒有 他買很高
所以我覺得我的壓力很大
我說我這樣壓力很大
所以我跟你講
我真的是人在做天在看
我覺得應該很少人像我這樣
真的是很在乎你們的感受
也很在乎你們賺錢 賠錢
所以我不認識
我跟你講說
那你至少買個台灣50
有照做的其實都賺翻了
再來因為有些人攻擊我美債
莫名其妙 你們都不做
我至少講了快50遍有沒有
沒有50遍也有30遍
叫你美債換台灣50
你美債換台灣50
你早就賺翻了好不好
不要開玩笑好不好
台灣50這樣走勢
你不要這樣看啦
他現在比較弱
你們看週線就知道
台灣50還原 這樣漲
從35塊漲到115
一年多的時間漲到三倍
35塊有沒有看到 你自己放大
這樣一路漲
你美債賠10%
你停損了換了一個
可以讓你漲一倍的台灣50哪邊錯
人在做天在看
現在我要告訴你是 來
你有沒有覺得我預估能力很強
我說AI會一直缺
因為你要想一件事
我相信那些老闆
真的科技業老闆
智商不會比哲哲低
我看到的他們一定看到
他要AGI產生 他一定要拚第一
美國也在拚
我不只是企業 你們一直覺得企業
是國家也在拚
國家在投資AI
不然你武器人家鎖定
像伊朗那時候不是打到那個嗎
打到那個女子中學嗎 為什麼
因為以前那是個基地
那AI很恐怖
一次打是100個目標
你不用AI怎麼可以
很恐怖
以後打那個人很像CS一樣
打這個像野戰叢林
我看到你的時候可以全部人一起看你
我看到你的時候
我戴護目鏡看到你的時候
全部人一起看到你
你躲在裡面我也看得到
可以追蹤
只要你出現過躲在裡面
全部人都知道你在這邊
怎麼躲
那這個 所以美國說
我就算全部都贏了 武器都贏了
我AI輸你也沒有用
因為我可以用我的AI制服你的AI
如果中國贏的話 他這樣說
他的意思是這樣說
你覺得美國不會投資嗎
國家不會投資嗎
最多錢的不是企業 是國家
說AI泡沫的
說AI泡沫的根本不懂AI
說AI 每天講AI好
也不知道為什麼AI好的
你覺得他真的懂AI
哪個分析師像我講這麼仔細
你告訴我
所以我跟你講
我剛才講2018年
選律師也是這樣
要找有經驗
我看到這個東西就像2018年
停產又像什麼
又像去年的被動元件
像去年的記憶體
我AI的這些MLCC
不是MLCC
MLCC 被動元件分很多
MLCC又怎麼樣
備料或怎麼樣
標準型MLCC
被動元件
被動元件有分很多 OK嗎
轉向高階的
AI都會相關的 你聽得懂嗎
消費級停產 為什麼
我要轉單 我要去做AI
是不是 我MLCC車規的很麻煩
是不是 那怎麼樣
國巨就有了
因為具車用的產品布局
他不只車用
不只車用會受惠
其他被動元件都會受惠
華新科也是常規MLCC承接機會
都有
AI他會
AI的需求你想想看
你一開始想到先進製程
你有沒有看到成熟製程也會缺貨
為什麼
因為還有邊緣運算 邊緣AI運算
我知道講這些你都聽不懂
他就帶動整個科技業的風潮
你只要懂這個就好
你們要記得一件事情
現在已經有人在討論了AI毀滅人類
你就知道多恐怖
而且討論那些人不是危言聳聽的人
你知道他進展多快
你們要有危機意識
真的很多人被取代
你們要記得一件事情
有腦袋的人 我不能說你沒腦袋
有腦袋的人都知道AI進展很恐怖
我拜託你們多問一些東西好不好
像比如說身邊也有人
比如說我們公司
那個不是Uber不是要印那個嗎
Uber不是要印收據嗎
Uber印收據很麻煩
要下載檔案 下載PDF檔
就有人說投資長 這個我不會下載
我說你不要問我
這件事不難 怎麼處理
檔案換新的 Uber換新的程式了
我說你問AI就好
你就把他圖片截圖下來就好
不行就錄影就好
3分鐘過後就傳給我檔案了
我現在有很多助理問我問題
我會不耐煩
你有沒有先問AI
基本上你給他一個圖片就好了
然後問問題之後 他就給你解釋了
你們一天沒有問AI 10題到20題
都是不及格
代表你們都很危險
真的 你記得我這些東西
很多東西是這樣子
聰明的人就知道我在講什麼好不好
這個跟大家講
地球不需要人類
你們有點危言聳聽
就像有沒有 那個
也有很多人說
那個核子彈會毀滅人類 好不好
那至少你們也是很幸福
以後可以延年益壽了好不好
OK 這個跟大家講
我有日電貿 禾伸堂 國巨 華新科
我有沒有說 我就是喜歡國巨
可是我說其他被動元件也可以買
我有買華新科 我有買什麼股票
我不跟你講
可是我檯面上就是國巨跟華新科
沒有錯吧
拉起來 這個新聞是大新聞
還會缺 還會缺
矽晶圓也會缺
你看現在記憶體最大問題是什麼
記憶體最大問題是漲太多嘛
你看記憶體價格漲夠了
股價也漲太多了
你看 所以那毛利率會下滑
可是營收可能會增加
可是如果有一派是看毛利率的
那可能不一定會追記憶體
然後有一派說 循環學說
景氣循環學派 他是景氣循環股
你懂嗎 很多大師出的書告訴你
彼得·林區出的書是這樣講的
說本益比很低的股票
基本上都會腰斬
股價都會腰斬
他講的是對的
但是他沒有想過什麼是AI記憶體
這次可能不一樣 這一次不一樣
因為AI需求太恐怖
我講每一家企業
如果現在有人跟我兜售
說老實話
我現在認真用AI程式寫
我可以讓我們公司的人力
我這樣講我怕我們公司的人會難過
我可以讓公司的人力
或許可以少一半
但是我們不是那種狠的公司
我花時間 我去寫程式
我以前不會寫程式
我花時間去寫程式
我至少邏輯不錯
我記得我們那時候
預官那時候考那個計算機概論
現在當兵很簡單 4個月
我們那時候大概1年半以上
我考得比隔壁台大資工所的還高
我也是看一看而已
我有閱讀障礙
可是剛好因為預官考試都是選擇題
計算機概論就是零跟一
我只要會問問題就好
基本上你現在只要會問問題
邏輯夠好的人
你不需要當碼農 不需要寫程式
你也可以生出很多很好的程式來
你可以節省
基本上所有公司都有很冗長的流程
不對的流程
那個無限商機
人家是無限城 你是無限商機
很多人看不懂未來
3年10萬點
你以為我會拿我的名譽來開玩笑
當然我不會說肯定這件事
我是合格分析師 好不好
我今天看到一個網紅比較好笑
還說我們收費貴
我們就合格分析師
你知道為什麼收費貴
因為我們要找稽核
我們要找研究員
他們那些藝人網紅的
你覺得誰比較認真
這個有什麼好講的
我不要批評來批評去
我們合格的還被人家
我們合格的分析師
還有分析師的執照
還被那個連執照都不考的
都不用被監督的網紅
然後講我們收費很貴
你們不覺得這個世界很好玩嗎
但是我們不要講是誰
我只是覺得這個很奇怪
記得我們是合格分析師
記得找分析師要找最紅的
你們家有沒有
哲哲是不是最紅的 去打聽一下
不是紅一點點而已好不好
有誰100萬粉絲
只有一位
140萬的也只有一位
不要說100萬 80萬也沒有吧
是不是 OK
來 不過我說一件事
其他分析師也很認真好不好
我們台灣很多還是不錯的分析師
來 記憶體價格漲夠了好不好
所以這個記憶體價格
我們看一下這個記憶體
這個漲得很誇張
這明天還會續漲
明天國巨漲上去你不要說我沒說
國巨就上面冤魂很多
沒有關係
I don't care
趕快買
不要說我沒說
我就喜歡挑戰這種東西
還有什麼 看記憶體
8299群聯
群聯今天有點開高走低
但是這個新聞他沒有利空 為什麼
他今天有講了
他說這個記憶體缺貨
就用Flash來補
那他跟那些大公司關係很好
一定可以拿到料源的
你懂不懂
最怕是拿不到料源
所以他的EPS只會更漂亮而已
我跟你講明年
你說4 500元有沒有可能
EPS 我講的是EPS
不要嚇你
都有可能 好不好
4 500元都有可能好不好
這個跟大家講
4倍本益比 沒有關係
所以為什麼記憶體我盡量選群聯
你懂不懂
看日線圖
因為我就選漲不多的股票
我不選南亞科
因為漲太多了 你懂不懂
漲太多了
南亞科今天跌比較凶一點點有沒有
是不是
華邦電也漲多一點點
但華邦電至少這次回檔也是不少
好不好 OK嗎
我主要 我會先求不傷身再求療效
我主要還是在群聯
群聯缺點就是股價比較貴
聯發科股價也貴
也拉起來了
今天一根長紅K
你有沒有發現我的股票
都是好酒沉甕底
是這樣說嗎 對
你也不會講 好不好 來
友達呢
我跟你是友達以上戀人未滿
所以不跟你講
沒有啦 好 來
力積電也不好嗎
不跟你講那麼多
旺宏也有機會
Flash這一塊
只是他那個Flash
他們是可以自己產這些Flash的
OK嗎 來
旺宏還有救嗎
記憶體不會太差 好不好
發哥我買在4000還能加碼嗎
我覺得買在4000很漂亮 先抱著
會不會加碼
我不會跟你講那麼清楚
那誰要參加我的會員
我沒有一定要你參加會員
但是我要替我們公司其他員工想
好不好
我們還是要招收會員
當然不勉強 OK
謝謝我男神 我華新科賺錢
賺翻了吧
我們華新科應該全部人都賺錢吧
除了今天買進
我今天還有買進 不好意思
是不是助理 問一下
哲哲 摺疊機會貼保護膜嗎
我們剛才說什麼顏色
我們剛才講到摺疊機 等一下
勃根地酒紅
勃根地是不是
是真的還假的 真的
勃根 第九個紅
有第一個勃根
第二個勃根 第三個勃根
第九個 勃根第九個會紅
好啦 隨便
開玩笑
摺疊機要買白色還是黑色
當然是買白色
白色512GB當然一定缺 好不好
人越來越多 怨念越來越高了
不用擔心 如果是以前我說沒救了
我以前那個時候
那個記憶體
不是記憶體
2022年那時候從那個
就是航運股
從200多塊跌到100塊以下的時候
那時候點閱率好高
我說我救不了大家
那時候我暗示大家
這一次我覺得我有機會救得了大家
而且你說人很多 也沒有很多
你看直播人數又變少了
你們這一群渣男渣女
沒有關係 我跟你講
哪一天國巨漲停板我就停播
我沒騙你
明天早點錄好了 我看
不讓你們只看尾盤
6000人沒有很多
前陣子1萬多人不是嗎 是不是
環球晶快8字頭
你緊張什麼 就買啦
當然你記得
所有的股票都是一樣
都不要持股超過5成
分散 也不要過度分散
我每次看一堆會員持股診斷
我跟你講一件事好不好
你如果股票超過20檔的
拜託你去買ETF就好 好不好
你就去買台灣50好不好
你不要浪費時間好不好
你持股20檔真的不要好不好
人家巴菲特這幾兆資金
波克夏幾兆以上的資金
人家 我記得沒錯的話
他80%的資金
還是持5股以內 5檔以內
那5檔就占他80%資金
他為什麼會贏S&P 500的報酬
就是他也是從S&P 500裡面
選比較好的股票
就這樣子而已 懂嗎
你不要持股那麼多
人家這麼多錢都持股這麼集中
再講一次 巴菲特
波克夏多少資金
助理幫我算一下
幾兆以上
幫我算一下波克夏持有資金
幾兆資金
80%的錢都放在5檔裡面
5個股票裡面
5股 5檔所宗
不要講5檔所宗
好像講我的政治傾向
5股裡面 樹林五股
5股裡面 5支股票裡面
20檔不要鬧了好不好
哲哲停播
我跟你講 真的會停播
我沒騙你
我不是停播
我就給那種有訂閱的
我們有訂閱一個月999
給訂閱還有給會員
趕快給我按讚
我今天心情不好 我跟你講
因為今天節目很重要 我跟你講
要按讚 不然到時候
500多人
你們真的是
要恐嚇嗎
今天沒有1000人
我真的考慮不錄
來啦 來啦 要求不過分啦
你要給我800個讚
結束沒有給我800讚
來 我沒有跟你開玩笑
我們通常會錄到5點半對不對
3點半嘛對不對
10分鐘內沒有來個800到1000讚
我今天不錄了 我要結束了
要給我先按讚
我再講一次
10分鐘內沒有給我800
最好是1000讚
我要結束節目
今天我要結束 要提早結束
哲哲就是跩 怎麼樣
趕快來按讚 感覺問題而已
這個也不是要你花錢
會有這麼多檔也是記憶體大爆衝
你們就是不要那麼多
管記憶是不是爆衝
所以被動元件不要持股那麼重好不好
不管啦
還是524是不是
等一下就結束 我不管
我說話算話
沒有800讚我一定停止錄
持股超過一半都是台積電
我不建議啦
當然其實台灣50
所以我就跟你講台積電是好公司
但是你還是要分散投資 好不好
按100次沒有用好不好
1000了 這麼快 還真快
你看 你們都要我恐嚇
我要哭哭 我跟你講
要恐嚇 這麼快
平常就這樣子
沒看過壞人
其實還少了5000個讚
再按一下好不好
我知道你們一定說1000個讚
好啦 算了
不要一直這樣恐嚇你
這樣你們會不高興
可是真的彼此在乎一下好不好
1000多 按一下
你們很現實 1000讚馬上就沒了
趕快按一下
再看一下有沒有
好啦 至少代表你們沒有睡著
1400了有沒有 笑死了
按一下 也要按一下
對 要按讚 不然真的不想講
你知道今天有個會員要參加
然後跟我講說 哲哲
聽說你都很晚才出清持股
廢話 我精材如果很快出清
我賺50% 賺30%就走了
我現在怎麼賺150%
哲哲 聽說看你的節目就賺錢
看我的節目賺錢還不好喔
所以我可能 我先不要參加
我說你不要參加沒關係
不要浪費我的時間
你要不要參加趕快說
因為繳錢繳一半
我說我很忙
我說我人那麼好不行喔
你那個被動元件有賺到錢
看你的節目被動元件賺錢
賺錢怎樣 買一張
買一張看節目會賺錢
那你就自己看嘛
要賺大錢來找我 要賺小錢看節目
不就這麼簡單
是不是 你看人在做天在看
很多人看我節目就賺錢的
賺錢不按個讚 是不是
1400了 按一下
明天被動元件有機會噴
我是跟你講 好不好
哲哲怎樣
按到多少剪指甲
我跟你講 按到2000馬上剪指甲
馬上沒有指甲 馬上剪指甲
應該說馬上指甲變短
因為昨天沒有剪指甲嘛 對不對
來 看一下
有沒有到2000
就是2000的話
就是很短的指甲
CPI推背圖
明天CPI很重要
我們看一下CPI
等你們喔
1600了 不用看我指甲了 謝謝
來喔 我們看一下喔
CPI只要3.4%對不對
我們CPI 3.4%要怎麼看
我們有做個報告喔
CPI裡面
你不覺得我們做的報告很漂亮嗎
真的很漂亮
我們不要講誰
我們最近培訓很多分析師
你看這是我做的圖很漂亮喔
然後你看
你不覺得這張圖就很醜嗎
就是還在培訓的分析師做的比較差
你看不覺得這個顏色有差嗎
你看別的是不是很漂亮
你看你光這一張
已經被我嫌到不行了喔
他改了5 6次喔
所以你去拿別的
別家投顧的分析師
做的AI圖跟我的比真的有差耶
你看我連這張圖我都罵得
導播我是不是一直在罵
一直在唸對不對
對 沒錯
這張圖喔
台積電市占穩居龍頭
我就覺得這張圖根本不漂亮
連這邊都給我黑色的
你看我多變態
你看這張圖就很漂亮有沒有看到
你看我要求很高的
你看這張圖就這樣
看這張圖有沒有
這個有沒有錯
這個AI圖就很漂亮有沒有看到
這是新聞啦
所以你看我的要求
你看我只拿我們團隊內做的圖喔
你看一個是我覺得合格的
有沒有 這兩個合格
一個是我覺得不合格的
你就覺得有落差了
更何況別人不是我們團隊的呢
不是我們摩爾團隊的
是不是 我剛才講到哪邊
對 那個CPI
CPI看一下 看一下CPI
等一下喔 畫面
對 我們要講股票了
那最後10分鐘要再講股票
來 我們那個看一下
就是居住成本對不對
CPI都有增加喔
CPI他有說
就是價格漲1%的影響
這是什麼
好啦 我大概懂他的意思了
他說這一次啦
汽油怎麼樣
增比較多一點點 好不好
8月上旬風險比較高
我們把這個權重給他算看看
有沒有看到 這一次增加的
有些都有增加 有沒有看到
這一次喔 來
預期3.4%
有可能會爆一點點
我不希望爆
可是這個是我預期的
應該這樣講
就是下去的機率不高 但不是沒有
就是3.4%嘛 下去3.4%以下
3.3% 3.2%
可是只要3.4%以下
包含3.3% 3.2%
3.4%就好了
股市就會噴出去了
再講一次
只要符合預期3.4%也不會升息
股市就噴出去
所以禮拜五8點半的波動會非常大
你喜歡做當沖你自己沖
那衝要很快喔
要很快 好不好 OK嗎
這個跟大家講 來
我們順便看一下有沒有2000個
1600喔 真的不想看我指甲
大家都很現實
1800喔 來不及了
沒關係啦 給你看指甲沒關係啦
導播來看一下
你知道為什麼我不剪指甲嗎
我早就知道你們會問我
昨天我是不是節目說我指甲很長
我跟你講
我晚上第一件事就怎麼樣
剪指甲啦 你看我這麼變態
我的頭髮都一樣
我就要求自己剪指甲
有沒有看到 看到沒
有這麼乾淨的指甲嗎
你告訴我
有這麼乾淨嗎
是不是 這麼讚
畫面給我
我就是要求好不好
好啦 就是這樣子啦
要求完美就是我啦
所以股票要求完美
CPI很重要 重點是AI好不好
AI真的會取代很多人
你相信我講的話好不好
來 波克夏有沒有
波克夏持股10兆啦
助理幫我改變我的說法
前五大占比不是80%
是72% 也很多啊
10兆美金裡面
波克夏 你看我放大
波克夏有大概10兆台幣喔
10兆台幣的持股嘛
對不對 沒錯吧
10兆台幣的持股
沒有錯 9000億
10兆持股裡面有7兆
在5檔股票裡面而已
我都不懂你們買那麼多股票幹什麼
買那麼多股票真的來找我好不好
很讚很乾淨
我喜歡指甲剪到底
所以我不論跟你握手
還是不小心碰到各位
不會很刺好不好
好啦 不要再講了
大胸肌 要看大胸肌
我跟你講我最滿意的是胸肌
我是幹嘛 我是來相親是不是
好 夠了
來 我們看一下 喝個水
不要跟你開玩笑
我是分析師
看一下精材 來 精材
你看喔 我是不是說
你們都可以作證
我是不是精材說
這個中實戶洗完盤很恐怖
我說這個中實戶很猛
有沒有 那天還說法說會公布後
不是不好嗎 這邊
法說會公布後不是不好嗎
不好意思 一直漲
今天連5天上漲 扯不扯
所以看一下我們的簡訊
來 導播來幫我
中氣十足的唸一下今天的簡訊 來
好 9月10號禮拜四今天的簡訊
恭喜3374精材
股價已經連5漲
再創歷史新高
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺154%
財富翻倍
我們持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
恭喜3374精材
股價已經連5漲再創歷史新高
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺154% 財富翻倍
我們持續看好他 手上持股獲利續抱
154%
投資朋友什麼叫154%
很簡單
就是你的100萬變成250萬
1000萬變成2500萬
我的股票有價有量
精材還算市值算小的
我最恐怖的是國巨
我叫你All in就All in
我叫你漲停就漲停
明天我說老實話
我覺得明天國巨
漲5%以上的機率
半根漲停的機率
我覺得很高
我覺得高達70%
除非今天美股很爛
今天美股應該不會太爛
因為美股要爛也是等明天
等公布CPI
我覺得明天國巨
漲5%以上的機率很高
你自己參考 好不好
我只是跟你講預測而已
可是投資沒有一定
不要來怪我
尤其是那種
只是看我節目的好不好
看一天節目的 拜託
你不要只看我一天節目又來怪我
賺錢都沒來謝謝我
賠錢都來怪我
No No No
這是精材
帆宣也是一樣
來 我們看一下帆宣
6196帆宣
台積電為什麼
台積電營收那麼好
AI需求無遠弗屆啊
你不要想那些變現不變現
明後年就會變現很多
很多人就會失業了
你看帆宣今天又在拉了啦
連續好多天在拉 偷拉尾盤啦
恭喜6196帆宣
股價表現不錯
今天的簡訊
收盤價再創一個月新高
我們多次買進
最高已經大賺50%
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
50%還沒走
還有人今天抱怨說
哲哲網路上說你很晚賺錢 很晚走
如果要賺100%
是可以一天就達到是不是
我當然要放久一點 不然呢
我精材不放久一點
我能現在賺到150%嗎
你們要賺5% 你們要買一張
賺10%就要走的
看我的節目就好
真的不要參加我的會員 拜託 真的
你們對投資有不當的期待
真的不要參加我的會員 好不好
說真的 明天我要結束了
明天晚上我10點半要結束
不是明天晚上 說錯了
今天禮拜幾
今天禮拜四
對 明天晚上
明天剛好公布CPI
明天晚上10點結束
化被動為主動
主動88專案
要結束了
就不要明天結束
被動元件化被動為主動
我跟你講
我現在這個
6173信昌電在拉囉
偷拉 MLCC偷拉囉
現在在拉囉
2492華新科尾盤這樣急拉
也拉了快一根漲停吧
這樣有吧
有 從這邊拉到這邊是10%
國巨 因為當沖國巨很難
國巨你明天不要看了
我跟你講明天都有機會
很恐怖 帆宣也是這樣賺50%
我就喜歡挑戰難度 你知道嗎
既生瑜何生亮
既生巨禾伸堂
禾伸堂多少 等一下
3026 好
3026有沒有 禾伸堂也這樣拉
這個是真的新聞
越來越像記憶體的故事了
這個缺 然後產能移過去
另外一邊也缺了
記憶體 高階記憶體缺了
所以我把低階的記憶體
產能移過去
變低階記憶體也缺了
低階記憶體缺了
DRAM記憶體缺了
我用Flash來補
變Flash也缺了
這個高階的被動元件
或MLCC跑去AI去的
或者是說我要把產能MLCC停掉
我用高階的去賺錢
不都是這樣的故事
環球晶也會 好不好
只是現在這個故事
記憶體故事真的有點像被動元件
1000多元的時候有人跟你講
你們就聽了
500多元的時候跟你講
我再跟你重複一次
1200元的跟500多元的國巨
有什麼差別
香奈兒打7折一堆人要
不要說打7折
香奈兒打95折一堆人要
香奈兒真的有打折
你們不要吐槽我好不好
打折是他們這個
譬如說那個晶華酒店或怎麼樣
他們配合的
這個101都嘛有回饋
只是1年才一次 兩次而已
香奈兒打95折一堆人要
股票打5折沒人要
還會幫你賺錢
很多人說買香奈兒
很多女生說買香奈兒會賺錢
買股票賺比較快好不好
這幾年 再看一下 來
群聯為何營收不錯還是不漲
慢慢來嘛
有時候 很難去預測每天的
好不好 來
威剛 創見比較多
這個因為他們的產能
他們是比較偏庫存的
那庫存少他們拿得到單嗎 OK
謝謝哲哲的世界先進
帶我飛起來
我看一下世界先進
現在幾分了
世界先進連漲2天
是不是要拉囉
這樣漲起來你就開心喔
那我的精材你不是愛上我
我不覺得這個叫漲
因為我真的是要賺100%
現在這種行情要賺好不好
中美晶跟環球晶一樣
我很看好 好不好
請問哲哲 大學生建議怎麼投資
怎麼辦 我好像大哉問
大學生我的想法是
我反而建議你的想法就是
一筆錢該衝就衝
可是你要接受能賠光光
如果你能接受賠光光的話
假設你大學生頂多10萬塊 假設嘛
就去壓 我反而建議你去當沖
然後去衝權證
知道自己的不足以後
以後會乖乖的做股票
你聽得懂嗎
或者你真的有天分
像我以前做一做
我以前做權證也賺很多
可是做完權證賺很多
我發現我是運氣好 我就不敢做了
你懂嗎
所以我反而建議大學生你要衝
大學生你反而不要去買那個什麼
那個什麼台灣50
我用另外一個觀念
你出社會買台灣50
因為你可能有經濟壓力 要養家了
大學生你就是一筆閒錢
爛命一條 命就一條衝就對了
大學生真的可以這樣做
可是不要用到槓桿
比如說10萬塊輸光就算了
不要去借錢 不要擴大投資
要衝一下
買權證 買期貨都可以
買微台 1點50塊的是不是
還有更便宜的對不對
可是上班族不建議好不好
年輕就是本錢
技嘉發GDR跟環球晶一樣
是不是也會盤整一陣子
那都是理由 也不是理由好不好
就是基本面還沒有一個大利多出來
對不對 OK嗎
還沒有大利多好不好
環球晶我覺得還是有機會
1000元以下我覺得都可以買進好不好
來 微星
微星我們看一下
微星怎麼看
微星就不要追高 沒怎麼看
你看是不是不要追高就很好
這個股票就不要追高
所以精材我就放著 我也不敢追高
很怕被修理
就是我跟你講
為什麼國巨好
為什麼環球晶好
拉回就做了 就這樣就好了
平常心 台灣股市要5萬點好不好
時機對了 風險不大 謝謝大家
我剛才跟大家講就是說
大學生那個東西
那沒有一定對
確定是不要
比如說你不能做股票
或做期貨做到
你10萬塊虧光光了
你會變得還要欠錢
這件事不能存在 1%的風險都不行
好不好 OK嗎
有人要這樣做 那我不建議
摺疊機
我有說我要買摺疊機 沒有錯
來 好了結論OK
所以結論
我們今天的股票滿多很漂亮的
我剛才有唸華新科嗎 有嗎
還沒有唸對不對
最後唸一下華新科簡訊 看一下
恭喜2492的華新科
股價午盤過後急拉
創快2個月新高
我們多次買進
最高已經獲利24%
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
華新科耶
創2個月新高 多次買進
最高已經獲利24%
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
華新科是這樣子耶
你看低檔我買多漂亮
華新科我幫了多少人
我救了多少人
所以你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師好不好
去想想看
我最後給大家一句話啦
這一句話我相信很多人都有感覺啦
好不好
台積電營收今天也創新高
等一下喔
沒有關係
我想說專案不見就算了
不要推 我很帥氣
看一下喔 什麼
等一下 沒有
助理以後那個放在AI圖裡面 來
我要跟大家講 來 這邊
最後一句話 這句話
來看一下
要選就選最紅的
有沒有錯
你們家有沒有
股票要選紅的
要選強的
分析師要選要選最紅的
你們家有沒有
今天一堆華新科拉起來
信昌電拉起來
被動元件拉起來 尾盤急拉
要選選最紅的
你們家有沒有
分析師要選 選最紅的分析師
哲哲不是最紅的 誰是最紅的
誰有百萬粉絲
所以歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
加我的LINE私訊我
來 最後這個專案你自己參考
要不要參加 請你自己參考
好不好 這個跟大家講
主動88專案
化被動為主動
明天截止
也預告各位
也希望各位能夠賺大錢
Byebye